[Música]
[Aplausos]
quantas pessoas você tem nas suas redes
sociais
quantas efetivamente você diria que
segue você influencia interessam pela
sua visão de moto
adicionamos e somos adicionado de forma
randômica muitas vezes perguntando
quantos amigos temos em comum
mas quem realmente seguimos alguns
seguem aqueles que ama odiar outros
aqueles que fundamentam as suas opiniões
mas quando isso nos ajuda de alguma
forma quando fazer parte de uma
comunidade ou engaja pode será o
poderoso sabemos de muitas histórias de
engajamento e mobilização política mas
quando fazer parte de uma comunidade
pode te ajudar a superar o desafio e se
tornar um recurso para além do dinheiro
meu nome é renato mas quando eu nasci o
time de futebol do meu pai ganhou a
libertadores da américa
ele queria que eu me chamasse vitória
celeste minha mãe não gostou e eles
decidiram que eu ia me chamar renata
pra mim o nome que você carrega exerce
enorme influência em sua trajetória e
crenças
você passa a acreditar nele e criar
significados
você até cria uma ficção uma narrativa
cujo principal personagem é você
eu brinco que me chamasse vitória e
talvez a minha história seria mais
linear e de vencedora nos padrões mais
reconhecidos pela sociedade mas como eu
carrego há 40 anos o nome renata
minha história não é linear ela tem
alguns momentos críticos em que tive que
me reinventar
renata significa renascer e preciso
contar um pouco dessas histórias para
falar o que eu aprendi sobre comunidade
eu sempre me interessei pelo estranho
por aquilo que não conheço
isso me levou a viajar sozinha a fazer
em tecnologia a receber ou a receber
hóspedes que eu nunca vi na vida antes
na minha casa
por mais que a gente seja criado para
não confiar nos estranhos
ele sempre me atraíram no final todos
somos estranhos antes de sermos
apresentados para falar da importância
em se criar comunidades
vou contar momentos em que tive que me
reinventar e que me ensinaram muitas
coisas em 2006
eu vendi a minha parte uma empresa pra
morar em londres e acabei juntando
dinheiro para viver um ano sabático o
que acabou não acontecendo porque na
primeira semana do meu retorno ladrão
entrou na minha casa e roubou todas as
minhas libras
nesse momento o único recurso que eu
conhecia para sobreviver era o dinheiro
e na falta total dele eu a princípio não
vi uma saída imediata
mas no dia seguinte tive um insight
olhei à minha volta e percebi que as
roupas e acessórios que eu tinha eram de
lá
e naquela época as pessoas não viajaram
tanto e nem tinham acesso às marcas
internacionais
fiz um bazar que deu certo até chegar ao
ponto de montar uma loja na minha casa
eu lembrava que na época que era
vendedora as clientes que mais compraram
era publicitárias
então eu liguei para as agências peguei
pegava os nomes de todas as mulheres
enviavam cacs convidando elas para vir
na minha casa
e funcionou o que mais funcionou era que
eu recebi as pessoas na minha casa
geralmente uma de cada vez e ficávamos
mais tempo tomando chá e conversando do
que propriamente comprando o que
acontecia
mas eu aprendi com o tempo que as
pessoas gostavam de conhecer um lugar
secreto um refúgio uma boa ouvinte das
suas histórias o que eu estava fazendo
começou a sair em algumas revistas
nacionais e jornais
até que foi denunciado por ter uma loja
em casa e tive que decidir se parava ou
ir para a rua abrindo uma loja com cnpj
meu marido me apoiou fizemos empréstimos
em bancos e nessa segunda fase deu certo
mas ficamos muito endividados em 2012
tivemos que fechar a loja com uma dívida
enorme que era muito maior do que as
libras que haviam sido roubados naquela
época a primeira iniciativa foi abrir a
porta da casa para vender tudo que
tínhamos e trabalhar ainda mais
mas não seria suficiente era muito
dinheiro pra mim e nenhuma perspectiva
de conseguir pagar os bancos e os
fornecedores
quando eu quebrei eu tive que enfrentar
não só a dívida mas também uma
deformação e crime virtual
muitos na minha cidade começaram a
compartilhar e difundir essa informação
essa foi a parte mais difícil eu tive
foi bia social era difícil sair de casa
mas era necessário e o mais assustador é
a possibilidade de perder toda a
reputação que eu havia construído ao
longo da minha vida
até aquele ponto e ameaça de perder a
minha rede
isso me deixou em pânico ea
possibilidade de não pertencer me
mostrou o quanto pertencer a uma rede
acaba sendo uma questão de sobrevivência
nessa época algumas pessoas me disseram
coisas muito importantes
um advogado de crime virtual me disse
que naquele momento parecia o mundo
mas era apenas um grupo de pessoas e eu
precisava reconstruir minhas redes criar
novos grupos e me reinventar uma amiga
me lembrava sempre do tamanho do mundo e
de quantas possibilidades esse mundo
poderia me apresentar e quando falei
para o meu pai que havia perdido uma
amiga de infância para aquela difamação
e que não acreditava ser mais possível
fazer amizades tão profundas
ele me disse que fez grandes amigos
depois dos 50 anos
então eu tinha as noções espaciais e
temporais equivocadas
era só um grupo pequeno eu tinha muita
vida pela frente e um mundo a ser
explorado
eles me fizeram ver que ainda depende de
mim e de mais ninguém
eu precisava ser assertiva não queria
cometer mais erros e procurei uma coach
ela me disse que eu tinha que fazer um
curso de empreendedorismo em são paulo
que custava mil e quinhentos reais
eu achei que seria uma loucura pensar
naquele momento em pagar esse dinheiro e
ainda falar em empreender mas ela disse
que eu precisava aí que eu arrumasse uma
forma e que eu entenderia depois segui o
conselho dela mas foi um ponto um pouco
cético
o curso era era uma semana de segunda a
sexta e na quarta todos teriam que
conseguir vender a sua ideia ou produtos
da sua empresa e arrecadar o valor de
mil e quinhentos reais o mesmo valor do
curso
mas eu nem tinha uma idéia e avisei que
não teria como participar dessa
competição na quarta à noite eu fiquei
bastante ansiosa pensando que tinha que
tentar alguma coisa e uma pergunta não
saía da cabeça o que te resta quando não
te resta nada pra mim estar quebrado
inviabilizaria qualquer negócio
até pensei só me resta me
mesmo comecei a pensar nos amigos e
conhecidos e em tudo que era procurada
para ajudar a fazer
informalmente comecei a ver que era
procurado por diversas razões assim como
todos devem ser aqui na sala
sempre somos associados a temas e
situações
e aí eu pensei em tudo aquilo que as
pessoas procuram a china e não querem
fazer aquilo que costumo dizer que
pagariam para alguém fazer por elas
pensei eu posso ser essa pessoa aí fiz
um post perguntando o que poderia
resolver por 100 reais
se eu poderia ajudar em algo quem sabe
resolver algo maior por 1.000 e 1.500
reais
perguntando se eu poderia trabalhar em
algum projeto ou serviço que me vissem
capacitadas em cinco minutos as pessoas
começaram a responder e pedir que eu
resolvesse problemas mais básicos em
algumas horas eu tinha dois sapatos para
engraxar duas sandálias para trocar o
salto vários presentes para colocar no
correio e ipva em atraso para pagar
pessoas para acompanhar um médico um
armário para organizar dentre outras
coisas e cinco mil reais
até então o recorde do curso serão 1.200
reais e eu consegui bater os cinco mil e
podia ter dado mais
mas teve que encerrar em 12 horas
arrecadar o valor do curso e voltei com
3.500
esta foi a ideia que apresentei para a
banca e eles me contaram sobre uma
plataforma de economia compartilhada que
se chamava teste rebate e que fazer algo
muito parecido
foi aí que eu aprendi o que seria
economia compartilhada e comecei a
entender novos recursos para além do
dinheiro
foi meu primeiro contato com esse
formato e isso iria mudar a minha vida e
minha visão de outro por causa disso e
fazendo pesquisas eu conheci o air bnb
uma plataforma que conecta quem precisa
de um lugar para ficar na cidade e uma
pessoa que alugou um espaço
eu tinha todas as razões para querer
para não criar um anúncio tinha vendido
coisas usa parte o apartamento tinha
três quartos sendo que dois estavam
vazios avião precariedades e o meu
prédio fica em uma avenida movimentada
da cidade ea fachada é horrível
decadente quase assustador
essas plataformas são baseadas em
recomendações e eu tinha certeza que eu
dessa sorte de ter uma consulta
seguramente eles iriam dizer sobre o pad
não haveria mais interessados mas quando
decidi fazer um anúncio eu chamei o meu
marido e fizemos um quarto lindo
aconchegante e bem decorado
mas o mais importante eu decidi que
seria melhor anfitriã do mundo e por
mais que saiba que há milhares já filmes
maravilhosos no mundo esse desejo me fez
fazer o melhor
criar experiências e hospitalidade para
meus hóspedes e não era muito diferente
do que eu já fazia na minha casa na
época da loja
vinte dias depois eu tive a primeira
consulta de uma família do rio que pediu
não só para ficar no meu apartamento mas
com o meu cachorro
como eu falei o estranho nunca me causou
receio e tem uma doença crônica de
confiar nas pessoas
eu mesmo e mesmo que eu tenha me
decepcionado algumas vezes
estatisticamente eu recebi muito mais
confiança de volta é que não olhamos
muito para quando as coisas funcionam
porque ficamos traumatizados quando nos
decepcionamos
mas a cada dia teremos que confiar mais
nas pessoas
os negócios estão sendo criados e
baseados nisso ea resposta cada vez
melhor acredite essa família do rio
deixou um comentário excelente e depois
dele recebi mais de 600 pessoas pela
plataforma e nunca uma pessoa citou o
meu prédio porque o que importa pra eles
e cheguei a perguntar depois numa
pesquisa é a experiência que foi
proporcionada o sentimento de
pertencimento e de hospitalidade ter
feito isso não só me ajudou a pagar
minha dívida como me deixou mais rica e
não pelo dinheiro em si mas pelas
pessoas que ficam meus anúncios todos os
dias
ainda na plataforma eu criei a
comunidade de anfitriões na minha cidade
e comecei a realizar inúmeros encontros
para tirar dúvidas e compartilhar
experiências
fui criando uma rede forte e com pessoas
que compartilhavam de uma visão de mundo
e uma prática incomum quanto mais essa
rede ganhava força mas eu era procurada
para ajudar as pessoas e o cenário foi
mudando meu redor
quanto mais eu acreditava nas
comunidades que eu poderia criar
- aquela que eu havia perdido me fazer
falta
descobri também que aquela não
compartilhava da
a visão de mundo e pouco tinha a ver
comigo o que explica a ser tão frágil
aprendi que se interessar
verdadeiramente pelo estranho e pelo
novo pode ampliar a sua rede de forma
muito poderosa pode fazer pertencer a
uma comunidade que compartilha dessa
visão de mundo e se tornar um recurso re
ao descobrir que sempre engajar pessoas
um dos projetos e que isso passa pela
confiança e verdade que você passa nas
suas ações
por isso é importante não se corromper
fazer aquilo que verdadeiramente
acredita e faz sentido
precisei da comunidade para ter pessoas
indo na minha casa quando tinha loja no
desafio de são paulo
é preciso mais do que nunca hoje abrindo
as portas da minha casa para estranhos
eles entram estranhos mas saem fazendo
parte da sua comunidade porque alguém
que chega na sociedade não é recebido
apenas por você mas por toda a sua
complexidade e você exerce um papel
importante de como ele vai formar a
imagem da sua cidade do seu país e do
que é ser brasileiro
o meu mundo hoje é feito de pessoas que
falam diversas línguas são de raças e
orientações sexuais diversas viveram
contextos muito diferentes e acima de
tudo confiança em mim assim como eu
confio nela e por isso que funciona
houve elas falarem do seu dia-a-dia e
cidade é muitas vezes mais rico do que
uma aula de geografia e história
é tudo sobre pessoas não sobre dinheiro
às pessoas que você consegue engajar
numa causa visão de mundo e quanto mais
legítimo e verdadeiro mais poderoso a
minha rede cresce todos os dias e mais
pessoas dividem suas histórias com
amigos se hospedam na minha casa eu abri
a porta da minha casa para o mundo
entrar e isso me libertou e me permite
escolher a vida que quero levar criar
comunidades trata-se de confiar amar
respeitar e focar no que temos em comum
e não no que nos difere este é o recurso
mais valioso como seres humanos
precisamos do senso de pertencimento
isso é que nos conecta com as pessoas
não podemos pensar que a comunidade que
fazemos parte é melhor ou pior que o
outro
nem ficar numa bolha é preciso criar
comunidades abertas e está
constantemente curiosa e verdadeiramente
interessada no outro e se importar com
ele cuidar quando eu recebo alguém sua
melhor versão
a gente deveria tratar todas as pessoas
como se estivéssemos recebendo a visita
de um estrangeiro
o interesse cuidado respeito pensando
sempre no melhor para o outro
eu sempre escuto uma pergunta recorrente
qual quando um conto para as pessoas o
que eu faço
mas e aí as suas coisas existe ainda um
apego muito grande que é limitador e
impede que as pessoas dividam e criam
redes poderosas
o momento é importante para se criar
comunidades falar ideia de amor respeito
e à hospitalidade é um veículo para
difundir essas idéias e um terreno para
a empatia foi construindo comunidades
que me reinventei e se você é uma pessoa
engajada a doutora você consegue isso
que carrega isso com você para qualquer
lugar
é uma espécie de super poder e ninguém
consegue abalar isso nenhuma informação
posso ter quebrado algumas vezes mas
nunca fez pobre pois o dinheiro é o
único recurso a possibilidade de perder
o capital social à comunidade da qual
fazia parte foi assustador mas a
possibilidade de construir novas redes e
comunidades e entender que esse recurso
é muito valioso em poder online tornou
destemida mais forte mas corajosa mais
livre
o mundo hoje tem se preocupado muito com
as diferenças e isso está popularizando
e fazendo com que todos tenham que ele é
gente que lado estão
prefiro e sugiro que as pessoas comecem
a pensar no que os aproxima do que têm
em comum e que se encontrem de alguma
forma para levar isso adiante
é disso que o mundo precisa agora e mais
do que nunca
focada naquilo que nos reúne qualquer um
qualquer um pode criar uma comunidade é
um recurso valioso democrático só
precisa de vontade uma ideia empatia e
verdade sua visão de mundo fará sentido
para as outras pessoas
espero que ela seja para o bem
o senso de comunidade de pertencer a uma
visão de mundo é uma questão de
sobrevivência criar comunidades é um
grande recurso e há algo que torna
invencível porque não é mais sobre você
é sobre muitos obrigado